I have got four belly blasting
supplements you can buy many benefits of
magnesium and how to get more magnesium
rich if you've been following my
newsletter you've heard me talk about
supplements like vitamins herbs and
protein powders comprise 36 billion
dollars in annual US retail sales and
it's almost completely unregulated we
have developed ultimate male vitality
supplement with eight concentrated super
herbs an open marketplace has
facilitated experimentation but it's
also allowed products to flourish like
Herbalife which some claim is a pyramid
scheme that doesn't help users lose
weight allegations that the company
denies now under investigation by the
FBI and the Federal Trade Commission
Neal thénard are set out to bring
accountability to the market without
quashing its dynamism you don't know
what you're taking there could be a fish
oil or capsule that's ten percent
omega-3s that could be one that's 90
percent of mega threes there could be
what we found which is that about a
third of the capsules that are actually
on the shelf or rancid I think what lab
where does provides kind of this really
nice balance between some sort of
regulatory functions but at the same
time it's a it's a free market right it
were you can like anyone can sell a
product if you do something wrong will
catch you or like we'll do our best to
catch you but we're not blocking
products from the market we're not
setting up a tenure process to get to
market six years ago he co-founded lab
door with the goal of bringing more
transparency to the supplements industry
the company has received funding from
several prominent angel investors and
venture capitalists including Mark Cuban
and Y Combinator
are there any results that have really
surprised you either in terms of wow
this has exactly what it says and is
pretty effective or falling way short of
what it's promising yeah so there's
certain categories so if you look at
like like a vitamin D or magnet there
magnesium we're kind of these kind of
simple ingredients like creatine you'll
find that the vast majority of products
will be very good you know so it might
be 70 80 90 percent of the market is
clean and then there's other categories
like Garcinia cambogia is something that
dr. oz had been really pushing heavily
and when we tested in 2017 we found that
70 percent of the products didn't
have the active ingredients up to the
label the company buys the products
right off the shelves and then post the
test results for free on its website it
makes money when people click through to
purchase an item people might think
there's a conflict of interest there if
you are testing these products but also
in a way marketing them how do you
justify that well often what we actually
find is that it's not the most popular
product that wins categories it's not
the thing that the big brand name that
you might have heard of often is like a
B or C grade on our site the real top a
grade products tend to be something that
people haven't ever heard of before so
it's the the protein powder from England
it's the official from Belgium these
companies in some cases have never even
sold in the US and once we find them we
start testing they actually find a
market in the US to actually start
selling fish oil doesn't sound that far
from snake oil yeah what did you go in
thinking about supplements and have you
changed the way you've thought about
dietary supplements I think I probably
went through three phases of my life so
like when I was in high school and I was
playing sports it was like I would take
the pretty parts in the creatine sand
whatever it like I I just I wanted to I
would buy what I was the most popular
right or whatever like my friend
recommended right and that's kind of the
the classic thing that people start with
and then you know I went to college and
I started researching a lot of the
science behind it and it would just hit
me I kind of went the other way and I
was like I don't want to take anything
because I like I don't know what's in
these products right and then once we
started testing these products you can
definitely find like we found protein
partners that say they had they claim 25
grams of protein per scoop and they had
5 or 10 grams and someone took the worst
product every single day they would
actually absolutely get sick right and
if they took the worst fish oil like
that had 10% a less than Omega threes it
would wouldn't be that effective right
and so this idea of we can find out
what's safe and effective just by
testing the products and if we can do
that then any he only took the best
products then you would actually see an
effect and so I think the sump'n market
has a lot of great players and a lot of
bad players right and our job is kind of
be the referee and has separates it to
lab door once tested male libido
supplements marketed by Infowars
Alex Jones though taking them is
unlikely to increase libido they
probably also won't do much harm the
company found both sides got what they
wanted out of that story like I've shown
just really excited that was all it was
all pure and and I think right and I
think the other side of the media was
very kind of frustrated about the kind
of the extreme claims that were being
made about what might actually happen
here how for us like we do the testing
we tell you what actually happened and
it and I can read that in very different
ways then it our plans to create a
decentralized network of laboratories
called test consumers would no longer
have to trust a single third party
including lab door or the FDA instead
through a decentralized database known
as a blockchain participants including
the supplement manufacturers themselves
could actually place bets using tokens
issued by tests as to whether a product
would passed muster in a Classics
certification somewhat like the company
would pay for a certification and we
would and like anyone would deliver it
and I think that that centralization can
cause kind of some bias when you
directly paying the proof the people who
are giving you a rating like a credit
rating agency you have a lot of risk we
want to use this token as that curation
mechanism for for this registry so that
we can basically have an open
decentralized way for one any lab can
come in and if they're registered if
they if they pass the testing they can
actually they can contribute they can
actually make money as a testing lab for
this registry and so it doesn't just
have to be us anyone can do testing and
so I think it's becomes a self-selection
mechanism where the best companies the
best products will actually rise to the
top by just the factor of this kind of
this curation this prediction system and
the idea of the best companies kind of
self-select into the market and theodore
says his vision of a market solution to
consumer safety concerns isn't limited
to supplements lab door has its sights
set on another giant market marijuana
it's a market that's basically gonna
come out of nowhere and there's a lot of
testing to be done there's a lot of
inconsistencies here in California now
with recreational legalization yeah
there's actually mandatory testing and
there's a whole system of labs so how
does your vision fit into that
I think the biggest thing for that is
convincing people to test publicly don't
like if there's a hundred things on the
show if you don't wanna know the 10
things that failed you want to know the
number one best thing right like if
there was like a spotlight that like it
was like this is the number one best
product and you just like take it up and
walk out the store that would be magical
right and that's the kind of experience
we're trying to make is like take those
hundred products and turn it like put
the spotlight on the one best product
and that's the more than just saying hey
it passed got like the minimum
government regulations it's like this is
the best product just buy this and
you'll be happy and that's the thing
that we're really trying to get to